un pénis de chair c'est un pénis qui a
une taille en érection qui est assez
proche de sa taille au repos il grossit
un peu il s'allonge un peu mais pas
beaucoup il gagne surtout en rigidité et
donc le pénis de sang à l'inverse sa
taille elle augmente de façon plus
spectaculaire avec l'érection les
figurez-vous qu'une étude a été menée
sur le sujet cette étude est là d'abord
permis de confirmer l'existence de ces
deux types de pénis le pénis de chair et
le pénis de sang les trois quarts des
personnes étudiées ont un pénis de chair
et Il gagne en moyenne 3,1 cm en
érection contre 5,3 cm pour les pénis de
sang autre enseignement la taille
moyenne des pénis de chair en érection
et de 13,1 cm contre 15,5 cm pour les
pénis de sang ça voudrait dire que tout
le monde part à peu près de 10 cm au
repos mais que les pénis de sang
grossissent plus et qu'au bout du compte
ils sont plus longs et surtout n'oubliez
pas ce truc important des pénis il y en
a de toutes les tailles et de toutes les
formes donc aucun complexe à avoir
chacun est différent chacun est normal